stockfish 12 has won the tcec super computer
tournament now this is a watershed moment in
computer chess it definitively shows that
this new approach that stockfish 12 uses
that includes brute force computing
looking at millions of positions per second
and neural networks that deep
positional understanding that leela has
is the strongest approach available today it
will probably require another watershed moment
in artificial intelligence to
build a stronger type of chess
engine without further ado let's look at one of
my favorite victories from stockfish in this event
an amazing sicilian game as i've already indicated
here the opening is a sicilian we get e4 and c5
now the opening moves are dictated by the tcec
so we're going to zip through here to move six
that's when we get the interesting move 6g4 in
this position this is the fifth most popular move
in this position to a human this would look much
more natural if the knight were already on f6
then this would basically be like a carries attack
one of the strongest openings available to white
in the sicilian depending on how black plays
but in this case the move looks a little bit
premature to a human at least but it turns out to
be very strong it's important in looking at these
opening moves to understand the tcec the tcec
picks the opening moves to ensure interest and
diversity in the positions and then both engines
have to play the position once with white and with
black so in this case stockfish has white but in
the game before this it had black and had drawn a
long and difficult game so here after the move g4
both engines continued in the same way we get h6
h4 pawn to a6 and now a move that i would not have
considered knight takes c6 now possibly partially
due to the influence of engines we're seeing
more of this kind of move in sicilians but at
least instinctively to me and my classical chess
education it seems very odd to trade an active
knight for a more passive one and to reinforce
the center for your opponent when you do it
and then to allow them a half open b file that
also looks pretty useful as well however it
turns out that this is really kind of good for
white because the pieces jump to active squares
and black's pieces are struggling in some
ways and particularly it becomes difficult
to develop the king side over here for reasons
that will break down in a moment in any case after
the recapture here on c6 the move queen d3 is
played by stockfish now in its game against leela
when it had the black pieces lila had continued
with queen f3 and then there was the move d5
so this game is going to develop on entirely
different lines after the move queen d3 i think
a very human move would be rook to b8 but then
good is b3 and you have the idea of bishop a3 and
castle's queen side in some lines now i don't know
about you but i've never seen a sicilian where
you play bishop a3 but the idea of that orphion
kettling the bishop turns out to be really really
strong and effective in this particular opening
it's not like it's winning but it's certainly
a worthwhile idea for white in any case in this
game the move knight to f6 is played and of course
that invites the advance of the g pawn so we
do get g5 pawn takes g5 and bishop takes g5
now this structure over here isn't one that i see
too often in a sicilian the position here with you
kind of having opened up the half open h-file for
this rook over here you having a pin here but it
turns out to be very strong and we'll see some
of the tactics that stockfish gets as a result
so after the recapture with bishop takes g5 we
see queen b6 attacking b2 and castles now you
would have to be a very greedy player i think
greedier than yasser sarawan to consider queen
takes f2 in this position you're underdeveloped
and you should not be capturing pawns like this
of course there is a punishment and it is swift it
is the move pawn to e5 you can't capture because
there is mate and although you can avoid mate with
for example knight d5 there is now knight to e4
attacking the queen winning a pawn back on d6
and obviously maintaining a huge huge lead in
development so after castles we instead see
the move pawn to a5 over here on the queen side
now queen to f3 bishop to d7 bishop to c4 rook b8
of course we're not going to drop b2 the computer
will never drop b2 bishop to b3 and now in this
position i think it's important to note that
bishop e7 kind of seems like the most natural move
here but it turns out that after h5 the idea of h6
undermining the knight on f6 is really strong
and it's hard to hold this position for black
well impossible to hold this position for
black as a result it's basically impossible
to develop the king side and that's a big part
of stockfish 12's advantage in this position
so the move c5 is played black is banking
fully on counter play on the queen side
there's possibly the idea of pawn to a4 and a more
serious threat seems to be the move pawn to c4
when you don't want to capture because you'll
drop b2 so you might win the bishop here on b3
but it turns out that there is a
way for stockfish to allow this
pawn to h5 the threats on the king side are
more serious than the loss of the bishop on b3
if you play pawn to c4 here very deep analysis
shows that h6 is winning for white it turns out
that you can give up the bishop on b3 and after
the recapture your king is totally safe and the
threats over here on the king side are going to
net you a piece back at least or a winning attack
now the idea of just capturing hero on g7 and then
capturing on f6 is of course immediate and very
dangerous so the knight kind of needs to move
from f6 but if you try knight h7 there is then
bishop to e3 pulling back the attacked bishop and
attacking the queen in turn queen to b7 h takes g7
bishop takes g7 and now queen g3 it certainly
doesn't seem like white should have so much
but in this position after this bishop is either
exchanged or removed from this diagonal in some
other way by being chased off there's going to be
too much pressure on the h file and the queen can
come into g7 it turns out that this will win
material back thanks to the tactical problems
due to this pin and that's going to be enough for
a winning advantage for example bishop f6 and the
excellent move bishop to d4 trying to exchange off
that bishop if you try to keep it with e5 there's
knight d5 and white's advantage is decisive you
can also consider knight to g8 but then again
pawn takes g7 bishop takes g7 and you're going to
invade on the h file after rook h1 and for example
bishop e5 rook h7 this pawn is too soft and again
white's advantage is decisive very very nice very
deep stuff so after pawn to h5 what we actually
see is a4 now it's possible to play knight takes
a4 because if the bishop captures you can capture
back with check so there's no time to capture here
on b2 and after knight takes a4 we get queen to
a5 trying to get some counter play over here on
the queen side so queen to a5 bishop takes f6
and pawn takes f6 the knight falls back to c3
queen back to b6 queen to d3 stopping c4 here king
up to e7 a3 bishop h6 check king to b1 and rook
hc8 threatening again pawn to c4 with devastation
now queen c4 this move obviously stops c4 but it
looks very very superficial in fact if you showed
me this position without having seen the game and
the computer analysis i would probably think that
black is not doing so badly here after all this
bishop is unopposed on the dark squares it looks
like the king is safe behind this wall of pawns
and how are you going to kind of advance the h
pawn which should kind of be your trump in this
position but deep analysis shows that white does
have dangerous threats here there are ideas like
pawn to e5 and other ways of breaking through
and black can really do nothing in the position
so rook c6 is played now look over to e1 it
certainly looks like the build up is very
dangerous here but how do you break through rook
c7 rook to d3 and the losing move is the next move
but it may already be impossible to save the
position at least it's very difficult for black
for example a natural move like rook c to c8 here
allows e5 with a very very strong maybe decisive
attack capturing with this pawn opens up the
possibility of invasion on this diagonal which is
dangerous and capturing with the d-pawn instead
opens the d-file which is also very dangerous
the king is not feeling safe on e7 and this
idea of pawn to e5 is a problem and there are
other ideas that also increase the pressure
and black is tied down without counter play
so in the game the move bishop f4 is played and i
think having seen the way the game develops that
we can say definitively that this is the losing
move but it takes one of the deepest combinations
that i've ever seen to show that it is the move
knight to d5 check this is an amazing move it
looks simple but it's very deep and white will
have to invest more material to break through
now of course knight d5 is forking all the things
everything in the black camp basically is forked
so you must capture the knight pawn takes pawn
takes and this has opened up an attack on this
bishop here on f4 and of course there is the check
now on the king on e7 so the only way to keep the
material is bishop e5 now at this point you might
be thinking that wasn't so deep i just play f4
pin it and win it i get my bishop back and come
on that's easy of course the computer saw that
i just can't believe it was allowed but in this
position there is bishop b5 with a counter skewer
and it is black who wins so what is the solution
it turns out to be the very patient move queen to
h4 avoiding the skewer here and threatening rook
takes e5 pawn takes and then d6 check for example
if c4 with a fork here then rook takes e5 is
more important white's threats get there first
pawn takes d6 check and white is winning but there
are alternatives right so after queen h4 what if
you move the king well basically white's ideas
white's ideas still include rook takes e5 or pawn
to f4 so if you try for example king f8 then f4
is just too strong if you try bishop d4 here you
could actually go for rook takes pawn takes you're
down a rook but with queen takes here intending
something like pawn to h6 and multiple other moves
then you're just winning the game the massive
pieces over here on the queen side is irrelevant
certainly the king is what matters in this case
so it makes sense that king d8 was played in the
game the king is trying to run over to this side
of the board where it hopes to be safe but now
there's another amazing move rook takes e5 anyway
after rook takes e5 white is going to be down
a full rook without a good hope of recouping
most of the material right away pawn takes e5 and
you might be expecting d6 but this is actually a
mistake that encourages the rook to go to a better
square stronger as played in the game is rook to
f3 and tending rook to f6 and of course the h
pawn is also a problem as indicated after king c8
and then h6 in this position and this is the game
now this is a good moment to pause and assess a
little bit white is down a rook and as the king
is running over here there is certainly no hope
of checkmating this king anymore white only
has two pawns for the rook how can this be good
well it turns out that white only has two pawns
for the rook now but a lot of black's pawns are
falling very very quickly so white will soon have
not just two but three and then four and then five
pawns for the rook and there's not a lot black
can do about it also black's pieces are not really
able to do anything effective in terms of counter
play and the h pawn is pretty strong now black can
kind of deal with the h pawn but doing so will tie
down pieces so all of this mounts up to a winning
position for white if you for example play c4 here
which is the only attempt for counter play here
there is h7 threatening to promote with check king
to b7 and promoting here is too early because of
the simple capture and then the capture of
this bishop uh although i don't think you
can capture the bishop right away but the
strongest move here is just bishop takes c4
threatening rook to b3 threatening promotion and
because the king is on b7 there is no mate on b2
so after pawn to h6 and then king to b7 we now see
bishop c4 bishop a4 rook takes f6 three pawns for
the rook queen a5 the excellent queen e4 which
threatens this and controls e1 no check from
the queen and bishop b5 d6 check bishop c6 queen
takes e5 four pawns for the rook rook over to e8
queen f5 rook d7 rook takes f7 and five pawns
for the rook so we're back to material equality
and clearly winning here queen d8 rook g7 king
b6 b4 as a human you probably would not want
to open up your own king in this position
you would want to play more conservatively
but the engine of course is calculating deeply
it's not concerned about illusory threats to the
kink it can see if there's actually any substance
to those threats pawn takes pawn takes rook takes
g7 queen to c5 check king b7 pawn takes g7
rookie one check king up to b2 queen f6 and
it looks like white has gone wrong the g7 pawn
presumably the best pawn on the board is falling
however again these are computer engines they
calculate so deeply it is one of the strengths
of stockfish new is that it also calculates deeply
in addition to having deep positional evaluations
so it's calculated that after pawn c3 the loss of
the g7 pawn is okay because b5 is coming there's
no good place for the bishop to move it goes to
e4 and it's very impressive here that exchanging
this bishop off is still enough to win bishop
d5 check i think that exclamation point move
bishop takes queen takes d5 check and here after
king a7 the engine surrendered first off if you
go king c8 which seems natural because you want to
stay close to the possibly promoting pawn there's
of course check and then you have a skewer or
this square and you pick up the queen here on g7
but why did black resign after king a7 well it
turns out that d7 is just over right and you're
going to make a queen and okay there's like
a check but it doesn't lead anywhere this is
just winning for white but a human a human could
definitely still mess this up a very human mistake
here would be the move b6 check after the king has
gone to a7 in the final position now why would you
include b6 check the point would be that after the
king captures or falls back when you push d7 your
next move will be promoting with check that seems
useful that seems like a good clean calculation
that makes things a little bit easier for you kind
of giving you an extra tempo the b pawn doesn't
matter if you're making a new queen why not give
it up to make sure that you promote with check
well the problem with this b6 check move
is that it's too clever for its own good
you have king b8 by black here not capturing the
pawn and it turns out that the position is a draw
because of d7 and now rook b1 check exclamation
point king takes b1 queen g1 or queen gives
any other check and then the queen is going to
sacrifice herself there's no way out of the checks
unless you ultimately capture the queen at some
point and when you do it is stalemate with the
king on b8 but of course a computer's not falling
for that in the past it might have happened
but not today and after king a7 resignation is of
course justified i hope that you've enjoyed this
game congratulations to stockfish 12 on winning
the tcec congratulations to its developers on
their great achievements in computer chess if you
want to see more incredible games from stockfish
or from lila then click on the playlist that is
popping up on your screen right as i finish here